[Applaudissements]
maman c
[Musique]
je
résidence très très bien c'est vrai non
non je reconnais qu'il en serait bien et
quoi les bons danseurs sont toujours
débout [ __ ]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et
non
[Applaudissements]
m
hdc votre avis on est en studio on est
potes un moment vous l'appelez j'appelle
mhd par son nom de scène mais je sais
travailler c'est pas le pied je sais que
c'est pas son annonce et ses initiales
c'est quoi son nom alors mouloud je te
promets mais tu voudrais te promet aussi
que je veux être augmentée ça c'est vrai
qu'au coeur ce projet mais les
maquereaux drôle et soe petit bras
déposé dans ta loge même si tu les mange
pas oliva j'y crois comme à calais ils
croient comme gilbert losc et sort et on
mercadier j'y crois qu'au matin pour mon
petit abricots et cet oiseau promet une
année différente et nouvelle j'ai tord
besoin d'y croire au camp merci à vous
merci à denis mercier
[Applaudissements]